este estadio es su mamá fue el epicentro
de la victoria de Francia tres goles por
uno ante Polonia los hinchas antes de
este partido habían llegado con
muchísima confianza de lo que pudiera
ser su selección se fueron con
expectativas aún más altas Estamos
contentos fue un buen partido hubo
muchos goles Esperamos que lleguen lejos
nos vemos en semifinales por mi parte
estoy muy sereno mínimo llegamos a la
semifinal un gol de Olivia llegó y un
doblete de kilian mbappé dieron la
victoria a Francia Bolivia llegó con
este tanto se convierte en el máximo
goleador en la historia de la selección
francesa sumando ya 52 goles Y ambos
jugadores están haciendo soñar a la
hinchada francesa
muy buen equipo el de Francia
kilian mbappé ya lo esperábamos nos hizo
disfrutar
estamos en cuartos el objetivo ya está
casi alcanzado hay que continuar así
mágico mágico traigan la copa a la casa
Vamos lebru vamos
pero para traer de nuevo esa copa a casa
Francia tendrá que jugar ante su partido
de cuartos de final partido que
disputará el próximo sábado